cette petite boîte de plastique vous ne
la trouvez pas dans le commerce pour
l'acheter il faut participer à des
réunions autour d'une tasse de thé en
présence d'une hôtesse c'est son nom qui
vous présente ses différents modèles
c'est un procédé de vente directe qui
nous vient des états unis et qui marche
très bien en france depuis de nombreuses
années c'est ce que l'on appelle la
méthode tupperware puisque ce fabricant
est le seul à vendre de cette façon
alors une ménagère qui met son salon à
la disposition d'une démonstratrice une
dizaine de voisiner d'amis invités pour
la circonstance c'est une réunion
tupperware une formule de vente directe
qui nous vient bien sûr les états unis
et qui a rencontré en france un succès
fulgurant
car des réunions comme celle ci il s'en
tient à peu près 4000 tous les jours ce
que vous assistez souvent à ce genre de
réunion
oui oh combien jamais des sommes
astronomiques a multiplié par des
milliers de fois cela donne un très bon
chiffre d'affaires gardé secret
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui quinze ans après
son implantation en france la société
tupperware peut-être en usine
ultramoderne à tour est grâce à son
réseau de 10000 démonstratrice et avec
la collaboration bénévole
les hôtesses qui organise des réunions
et l'a complètement révolutionné le
marché de la vente directe
le secret de cette réussite un bon
produit sûrement mais aussi l'art de
vendre sans trop en avoir l'air
quand même se demander qui a pas un
petit piège si on joue pas sur les bons
sentiments sur le fait que la
consommatrice notre apport refusé à son
ami enfin j'ai senti de la vente forcée
je pense que la meilleure réponse à cela
c'est que nos invités reviennent et si
elles reviennent c'est parce qu'elles
ont fourré un service justement je pense
que
disons à chaque fois qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation d'achat et c'est vrai et
que le but d'une démonstration est aussi
non seulement de vendre quand même une
affaire commerciale mais également
d'apporter un service
vous pouvez aussi mettre des crêpes ou
un service rendu oui mais seulement à
domicile et à l'occasion d'une réunion
car le refus de vendre autrement qu'en
réunion est érigée ici en principe non
pas nos produits dans le commerce parce
que ce qui fait l'intérêt de nos
produits ce sont essentiellement les
différents couvercle grosses têtes power
et ses différents couverts dans leur
conception et dans leur précision besoin
d'une démonstration de façon à ce que
les clientes sache lesquels sont
étanches lesquels sont hermétiques et la
façon surtout de poser ses différentes
ouverte n'est pas la même pour chacun
elles ont apporté une explication à
chacun les consommatrices qui
participent à ces réunions sont
généralement enthousiastes c'est un fait
pourtant il ya parfois des réticences
car et c'est en définitive le problème
il n'est pas très facile de partir les
mains vides n'est pas le changement va
peut-être un petit peu obligé d'acheter
puisque vous êtes avec des amis il eu
égard à l'hôtel on est quand même un peu
au coucher de zone d'acheter puis
j'achète parce que ça m'intéresse
[Musique]